[Music]
in unintentional investment news hmm
submitted by year boy boy and woman
finds out the $13 flea market ring that
she bought 30 years ago is worth way
bored how much I wanna know that days
now how come everybody else's good luck
with that stuff girl right I become I
get stuff like this we watch really less
than this I bought it I had a diecast
car because I really like the Nissan
300zx and then I decided to go with a
blowout closet sale and I sold stuff on
eBay and my car actually sold for 300
bucks because all this collector's item
which got me an idea said I need to go
find more of these cars because people
don't know the value of them so that's
when I started selling diecast cars on
ebay this is what happened to you then
see your story yeah yeah yeah yeah so
there's this woman from the UK and she
said in the 80s she went to a car boot
sale which apparently is really popular
in the UK it's the same thing as a silly
market they sell things out of their
trunk
no they party almost yeah trunk sale
don't sell don't sell yep everything
must go like everyone gets together it's
a lot of car and it's cute guys awesome
burgers I'm like oh that's not a car
boot sale is much do not do just a
little rider imagine it's just Saturday
night why you look at me I mean the
beautiful two point you got you there
look at that face II know you caught her
off-guard man I know you're giving a
compliment I'm not used to that chin
what I give a comment every single
minute
why should give it a look you are
awesome see he can't even think one of
them I mean I said you're awesome is
different he studied philosophy you are
I wanna add no see it yeah so she had
she's buses really big ring that she
thought was costume jewelry and so for
the last thirty years she's been wearing
it on the daily like doing tours
everything many people the space 30
years good [ __ ] sturdy ring yeah so
then she came across a jeweler and a
jeweler was like you know what I think
you should get this ring check because I
think it might be real so then she
pretended to tell her why didn't you
check it I like my actually like crazy
idea that I like a specialized person
exciting
you just lady he goes i appraise jewelry
that was expensive you should marry me
you [ __ ] [ __ ] what do you do right
now ah yeah so then um she sent it in
and found out that yep it's a real
diamond 26 carat oh that's freaking I
guess I'm 26 carats that's like a
donkey's been holy [ __ ] moly yo
how much is that worth how much did she
buy it for that Somali thumbnail size
diamond there's a 10 10 pounds Wow
can you guys I can't ever heard of a 26
I don't even I will say 10 million okay
then the millions like today that
100,000 50 G's he's not in a million one
hundred thousand dollars the 50 G's $200
more $20 so you live in true laughing
million one hundred dollars almost four
hundred and fifty five thousand sell it
no no joke that's like winning the
lottery
yeah okay I got a dollar ticket three
hundred and fifty thousand pounds
hundred and fifty five dude that's like
a [ __ ] what's it called like a Kobe
white thing dude yeah you know what I
got a deal remember I went with you in
case you to go by the desk and not
Venice yeah I bought a stack of mid
basketball cards for five bucks it was
like old eating these guy didn't know
anything about them but inside is like
Michael Jordan rookie card Scottie
Pippen and all kinds of cards in there I
could probably go on Becca comment see
how much they are worth break it still
exists
so I don't know maybe that's not but
that seems to be a magazine we have to
be like I gotta check my Beckett before
I sell it to you what is that it's like
a Kelly Blue Book of Kelly Blue Book of
basketball baseball hockey cards it's
kind of like values your card during
that time or whatever I don't think it
exists or not but I bought a stack and
all these are like David Robinson all
these classics like 25 you probably have
like hundreds of thousands of men $5.00
little yeah it's ours it is ours yes
you're like I'm glad I married you
yeah so this is a diamond looks like and
so they were saying that this is a 19th
century ring and so because of it
because of the fact that it's so old
it was cut in a certain way that it
didn't really bring out it's like they
were so much shiny and stuff fact that
they were lazy so I just look almost
like sake or look like glass or
something that's why she just started
with custom Dori so she'd been using it
for 30 years even like the setting is
beautiful do you realize that this
diamond was so ridiculously huge it
looked like a costume ring that's how
big that [ __ ] is it looks gaudy like
quick look like a [ __ ] ring pop
that's how big it is
which makes me carry the hottest lady
like what her style looks like because
if she wore it every single day I don't
care because it was yeah I see a lady
walking around with a edges like so you
funny she Shops at the [ __ ] thrift
store like you find like the most unique
looking [ __ ] there so she probably very
uh she looks like a mad really much lady
or she got some [ __ ] fat-ass fingers
I would keep this in the family for the
longest time I've sell that [ __ ] in a
heartbeat no you wouldn't
hell yeah why were you selling today for
half a million dollars
I was now that immediate no you can just
hold like it's getting more money's
giving you more money it's not money but
it's an 18th century
diamond ring that's like that's 19 I
don't think and how old is just a piece
of stone I rather have land
rather I want to keep it and then if I
guess like that's it I'm thinking about
my situation right now I don't need a
lot of money so it's like
I want a banana plant but I had a
[ __ ] tree
I want nothing all very not oh you don't
got you knees and I got it
I need a land barge oh you could pick
the diamond give me a land go buy some
land in Mexico and you can't even live
here
it's like Nolan unless you go to like
[ __ ] I guarantee if I buy land in
Palmdale a is cheap a hundred percent
but you can't live here anymore
you know honestly though if you if you
got that money what what's in it well
500k what is it pretty much no but if
you give half a mil cash that's
different that's like a million dollars
because if you if you buy a house like
it's on the market right somebody's
trying to sell this [ __ ] for like 700k
but you're like [ __ ] that I'll give you
five week a cash looking like that I'm
counting in a [ __ ] briefcase
yeah now they don't even know what to do
with it do you spend it on on frivolous
[ __ ] imagine what if although he'll know
yeah I probably get most of my tracks
and drawers you guys what about your
friends huh I said most of it off of the
restaurant in other words for me it's
not enough to share good this way I get
by yourselves I mean and I give like
let's I get like 300 K to my turn right
two hundred thousand what am i doing
that probably put down a house I mean
we're gonna do that yeah exactly yeah I
think that it's not enough to share
that's true half a million is a lot but
not a lot a lot yeah yeah you can't even
by talking away with that down a down
your bike down with it yeah singing
about it ridiculous that's really it I'm
gonna buy 30 acres in Iowa someday we're
two hundred thousand dollars bet you
can't I could do it no one wants a baby
relax if you're all about yeah life
there's too many armadillos there you
can buy all the good no but you know um
I went through ALP a so and they got
hail all like hell no yeah
you know what I am like pampered in
California because over here weather's
nice
and it's nice we got a little bit of
drought but it's cold you know
everywhere else is [ __ ] up dude yeah
we get earthquakes but [ __ ] it's just a
little bit of shaking you know it's not
like we can use I know it's kind of
scary like how quickly you're like we're
due for one but anyways what the hell
the owners of this ring are saying I'm
MMS they don't want their dinners ready
alright we try to get Jackson yeah so
they're reporting that this ring is
going to be up for auction in July she
does not want to keep it maybe she's
older she's like my kids are good having
cash money is more important than a ring
cos diamonds is artificial value true so
I rather have land or money cash money a
gold yep I think it's just I think it's
just crazy to me to have like a twenty
six carriers I really get out of it
it just had like this weird value to me
for not in the sense of like oh I'm
balling but it's like a piece of history
there's one of a kind yeah it's one of a
kind that's why it would be a little
differently and then almost like yeah
exactly like it's let's say a museum
would take it right but did give me
money for - yeah okay well if they
released it from yours yeah that's
volleyed would do oh well then I guess I
had to sell that she probably would buy
it though okay well I'm gonna really
forgot about it but it's pretty like
that's amazing though yeah I've never
good luck he should look good maybe you
have something in your possession that
you absolutely not my mom's goes away
everything like everything that had like
some kind of experimental value my mom's
like take a too much space she goes in
the box can that's awesome
she had a hoarder she's definitely not a
hoarder it was kind of I don't know the
kid I think I mentioned a story I hope
my tech Lundell gear and I'm like oh oh
yeah you did a monocyte you don't keep
this nope this right in the garbage can
right in front of me Wow sorta kinda
nice huh yeah I would like I would still
like to keep those things on my
accomplishment would you do it and keep
it in a box for me okay I seriously
though I don't think a lot of people
believe me look it's like it says
only thing I have like pictures that's
the perfect logging background you could
use it for art direction yeah he wasn't
even thinking like that I'm helping him
out so homie the point that's right
there right there right there I still
want my over getting you down every day
okay that's what sometimes it balances
out man yeah did she also throw away
your trophy yeah I mean I guess like
technically those trophies really are I
get to them in a real gold or something
United me it might be worse what
something but my parents are like it has
like little plastic shits just do it
away but I really wanted to keep the
headgear and looking like even though
obvious I can't fit anymore if it'll
still cool so you don't think you would
keep things exaggerated I would have to
certain extent like way my mom it was
pretty cool she kept all the memorable
things and then as soon as I was moving
on she's like here's all your [ __ ] and
what they did in my house anymore I
wouldn't throw it away I put it all the
bends
I'd be like this is ages one two three
four to it all because you're so
organized yet the most random [ __ ] she
kept homework
I still got that [ __ ] - I got projects
of me like making a spider that's just
like all associations I guess Isaac's
project - because I something he'll be
coming home he's so proud of the thing
that he made I'm like I can't find it in
my heart this is my project I was I
would throw that [ __ ] away myself though
yeah I did - grunt like once I got older
the big guys bought some homework and
project like I don't want any other -
minimal down marking like I wish I was a
kid it's funny to read that stuff though
you're like I was such a half-assing
sack of [ __ ] I don't you know what's
really what I just got it the other day
when I my very first girlfriend right so
like she thought this like cute little
froggy turned my head when I was a kid
should I was so cute she wanted to keep
it she bent [ __ ] still has it and I
want it back and I don't I don't know if
it's a follow up on the a well so how's
it been like gallery get away bro cut it
out you're not that important you threw
that [ __ ] away I [ __ ] killed of
course you do it away hell no she can't
throw it in my house it was like my
childhood Journal like you wrote in it
yeah my dad made me a cattle of the
journal and also write Bible verses
every day so I had a Bible verse one and
a child of journal so she wanted to keep
the journal thing so I gave it to her I
really want that back
because I want to know what the [ __ ] I
wrote yeah I trashed all my ex-boyfriend
[ __ ] well you're an evil [ __ ] though
that's very different
I'm very very very unsentimental little
people and so you met the man you love
right there so that's a different story
she I'm pretty sure she almost has my
old kpop CDs which I want those back
don't know any of those artist names
anymore so I got a bit of us wrong oh
they're up call right now yeah hi Gareth
Keenan a was called DJ doc one of them
was I think 6nh aunty I wonder if she'll
ever pick up her phone I can't do it if
you really alarming well she she was
like my best friend high school ah yeah
so all the numbers I had before if it
wasn't deleted I still have it but um
then actually don't remember that's
wonderful
hello my mother Joe Malians please like
the video and for more beautiful videos
look up there
[Music]
[Music]